benjamin castaldi il a un truc il adore
faire ce jeu de la patate de forain
benjamin vous allez avoir toutes deux
coups de poing avant de comprendre a le
plus fort nous le plus gros score
tous les chroniqueurs passeront d'accord
vous essayez alors c'est lui qui décide
s'il veut que je joue ou pas bah non je
veux pas donc je ne joue pas allez c'est
bon je ne joue pas tous les chroniqueurs
parce que si vous faites plus que tous
les chroniqueurs c'est à dire si aucun
chroniqueur n'arrive à vous battre vous
gagnerez votre anniversaire
cette voiture c'est pas une blague et
non ce n'est pas une blague du
spectateur
il est où
allez s'il vous plaît ses emplettes
benji badghis est magnifique il est
entrain et pleure à chaque manif
castaldi non mais c'est une blague
benjamin castaldi et betty donne tout
alors dites moi jamais qu'est ce qu'elle
me dit la floride study on comprend rien
n'a pas fait on comprend rien merci et
celui qui s'y joue pas alors on y va
attention c'est parti
cyril couanau le bas on vient de la
voiture non personne ne gagne ce n'est
battu personne ne gagnent la voiture
retournera chez son concessionnaire
voilà où les embrasse d'ailleurs voilà
ça commence par un p
ça termine à monsieur par attention
c'est par benjamin castadi c'est non je
me cassais avec benji anniversaire
attention c'est parti
basile navette donne pas trop on prendra
le meilleur score alors je comprends la
question est-ce que tu prends celui là
où est ce que tu as d'autres choses
il est bien sûr jamais fait autant
jamais fait autant dire dessus analyse
les deux j'ai deux essais alors la
direction
oui les actions non mais j en fais ton
2eme et 759 franchement si je fais pas
mieux j'ai gardé ça d'accord
areva n'est pas didier magne toi
sega mega drive et si cette fois il est
en forme il à 707 572 attention tous les
chroniqueurs ont passé et je dis si vous
arrivez à battre tout le monde on va
laisser isabelle le dernier single man
est un peu moins fort doute que je vais
pas faire plus loin les yb a fait le
quand même on va voir comment je sais
pas si c'est moi et m'a vu à gaza
simone benjamin il est tout émoustillé
merci regardez la vallée les médailles
mais qui parce qu'elle prit state dans
la gueule prête pas dit s'il est
magnifique je vous aime
bernard montiel attention bernard donne
tout mais ça se joue veille
quant aux uv
ah ouais quand même ouais l'union oui
c'est nul béni tamou toi tu apprécies tu
vas te blesser
djama fécond à 7,560 sais plus non mais
faut combattre et n'a jamais enregistré
de froid 3 772 bazille gilles jamain
castadi repart avec la voiture
c'est vous qui il va pleurer
bas du jour et à 572 arrête il est pas
mal mais aujourd'hui il est pas mal
aujourd'hui non gens me sens mieux
maintenant
jean-mi au médecin quand les spéculoos
attention comme 760 et or dont 106 ans
non non riga les chéris alors isabelle
et c'est là où on l'attendait isabelle
anormalement longs l'instant la voiture
est à benjamin castaldi le lag qui veut
bâti benjamin castaldi il n'aura pas
gagné la voiture si vous perdez il
repartira avec la voiture y avoir 6
pence hijab l on me dit on me dit qu'ils
avaient les blessés ah ouais on va
appeler on va appeler son remplaçant à
manu cibat chimiques taper j'appelle
arsène bulard
le champion du monde des lourds légers
[Applaudissements]
ces drapeaux du monde français
elle attend est-ce que regarder cet
essai à nice
c'était samedi soir à marseille une
réunion de boxe organisé par notre ami
thierry cheleman le directeur dé soir
par yves de canal+ est mon ami sébastien
acariès qui a fait une réunion
exceptionnelle samedi soir sur canal
plus et tu es devenu champion du monde
des lourds-légers un combat exceptionnel
je sais que tu as été formidable avec
ton adversaire après franchement je te
jure qu il faut le respect d'abord tu
meetic il faut de respect voilà parce
que c'est un sport très dur je c'est
vrai et pur très dur il faut rester
humble voilà il faut respecter
l'adversaire magna malgré ont fait la
guerre c'est un belge ou même fort les
belges et il a fait un super combat il
est très jeune et je pense qu'il va
aller très loin c'est ce que tu as dit
et toi tu es champion du monde des
lourds-légers c'est énorme ce que tu as
accompli
regardez c'était samedi soir est juste
après on va voir si benjamin cassel
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah ouais
les serres de paix alors en scène tu vas
avoir deux essais à 570 sabbath
14h12 772 frérot 1,2 kg
si je dois acheter cette voiture pour
qu'à celle du jeune et je suis très mal
et si j'ai réservé aux non alors si tu
regrettes dallas frère tu as la ceinture
à marseille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]